welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down secret Invasion Episode 3
the brand new entry has just dropped and
there's a lot of Easter eggs things we
learn and Theory times we have for
what's going on we're at the halfway
point of the series now too and I'd love
to hear what you guys thought on the
show are and if you're invested in
things going forward please drop a
thumbs up too and also make sure you
subscribe for our weekly breakdowns on
the series now last week saw Nick being
at his lowest point after watching Maria
die in his arms he went off the rails
with Talos and was also kicked out of
the government by number one scroll
suspect Roadie left with no editor he
finally finally decided to return home
which fine I'll come back and it's here
where we learned a crazy Revelation
turned out that Nick had actually
married one of the first Scrolls to come
to the planet and he walked back in like
Adam 22's wife with his wedding ring
left in the house either way the pair
danced out to Try a Little Tenderness
and it became clear he had a lot
invested in the war foreign
that takes us in episode 3 which is
titled betrayed beginning at the power
plant we watch Beto questioning the
resistance Mission and it's clear this
guy was just looking for a home
somewhere for food a way to watch heavy
spoilers until the good channel to
release their videos and just lie low
however he's been drafted into a war
that now sees him on the front line
taking on Royal Naval Service Officer
IDs we watch as they head out whilst
gravic gives a talk in front of the
machine in the core of the plant here
he's invited in the council members and
he discusses the next part in scroll
Evolution whilst the plan falls into
place ah
members of the council
glad you could make it on short notice
in case you missed our last video the
council members Rift slightly off an
idea that was brought up in the comics
though most of the Scrolls Focus their
efforts on imitating superheroes they
did spend time mimicking world leaders
in celebs we had a big two-page spread
where they appeared on screens
everywhere looking like politicians
actors and famous YouTubers please I
told you this girl shut the up Ryan
Airy and stuff like that didn't really
get too much attention because again
like I said they were focused on the
soups kind of funny though how stuff's
flipped around for the show with them
mainly focusing on real leaders and not
mimicking The Avengers now there's lots
of theories that were already been on
the entire time but personally I don't
know if it's just too obvious I would
love a little meta joke with Terence
Howard but if Brody's been out of the
running for a while then I feel that it
kind of robs his character development
so if that's the case I think I'm
getting swapped out would be quite
recent though we're doing that Scrolls
work amongst his people now we can see
that the Splinter Cellar off going to a
British submarine and this is so that
they can start a war even though there's
a million Scrolls there's still billions
of US unless the best way to clear the
borders to have us take out each other
humans warring with one another is one
of our biggest weaknesses and it's
something that graphiclider talks about
when he's with Talos he and his Warriors
are being carrying out attacks in the
world whilst posing as rival groups and
this is to raise tension amongst the
human race key Nations like Russia the
US and so on all of them can be places
that will happily go to war with each
other and once this is in place they can
just come in and claim the planet for
themselves now right from the off
graphic talks about another aspect of
his plan which is making super Scrolls
it's something we talked about last week
and a lot of people on Twitter were
quite annoyed that they'd done things
the wrong way around you see it's a rare
Twitter gets annoyed but you see in the
comics the super scroll initially
imitated the powers of the Fantastic
Four but them not being present in this
universe they've had to go about things
differently we do know however that
there are four specimens being used
which are groups DNA a frost Beast
extract premise and the Hand left behind
by color obsidian these four elements
are of course ripping on the four powers
provided by the first family though they
can't be used here because they don't
exist yet I will be talking about
something in regards to them later on
and potentially we might get a tease to
them now like I said people are getting
a bit angry about this but I think the
mcu's never really adopted things one to
one from the comics Hank Pym didn't make
Ultron in the MCU age of ultron's
nothing like the comic book and even
though Infinity War has a couple of
moments from Gauntlet they are vastly
vastly different secret Invasion itself
is a massive moment in the comic books
too but it's a far cry from the Spy
Thriller that we're getting here so I
don't think Super Scrolls will be the
same thing either and I'm kind of
viewing gravic's plan as a prototype
rather than the final version maybe when
the Fantastic Four are fully in the
universe we'll see something closer to
the comics but this is what it is for
what we have right now anyway with
gravic being a new character they can
kind of twist things from the original
Super scroll whose names clert clerk
born on the world of 10x4 he was
originally shunned due to the amount of
defeats that he and his Warriors racked
up constantly losing to the humans the
Scrolls then devised away to even the
odds by giving the Scrolls the powers of
the Fantastic Four in the MCU the
Scrolls of course lost their war with
the cree and thus they've also had to
find a way to match up with the Avengers
anyway Collette was given all the powers
which included the strength of the thing
pyrokinetic Powers invisibility and the
power to stretch his power to stretch
out now these are sort of made in the
samples we saw with the strength being
attributed to the frost beasts and curl
and Groton X drum is providing the
stretching in the fire retaining a
shape-shifting abilities clear became a
powerful assassin and he then paid the
way for the new Skrill Empire I think
that's going to be the case with graphic
2 and Clint's first battle actually saw
the heroes having to retreat he's able
to overpower all the characters in the
series as well and I think going forward
that he could become a big threat now
after the title sequence we cut to New
York in 1998 this takes place one year
after the the intro last week and it's
now three years since the events of
Captain Marvel meeting with Barra we
watch as she hands over some Intel the
fury and the name Drake covers mentioned
this was the villain Black Widow and he
was played by none other than Ray
Winston Black Widow actually started off
in 1995 and we had the big Escape scene
to kick-start the movie clearly Fury's
been looking into what's going on and in
many ways The Sleeper Cell in the US
could reflect the Scrolls themselves in
the comics Gaia was someone who is a
Sleeper Cell agent too just like Natasha
and she built the family on Earth whilst
carrying our missions she and her agent
husband Claire raised a family on the
planet and they were put in place to
keep tabs on everyone on Earth in the
past Fury was investigating people
infiltrating the country whilst we know
in the present he's investigating people
infiltrating the planet Fury and Vara
hit it off but he starts to question who
she's chosen to look like and I do think
we'll find this out later down the line
but let me know your best theories below
there was a leak going around that this
was actually Fury's original wife but
she unfortunately had cancer and then
Vara took over and decided to that they
were basically going to try and make it
work I'm bringing that up now because it
doesn't seem like it's the case however
I do think it's worth discussing because
that was one of the rumors going around
now the D aging I don't think gets
enough credit with this stuff and yet
fair enough Samuel Jackson hasn't aged
but both of them here look absolutely
great if you watch the new Indiana Jones
movie or the flash then you know stuff
can be a bit hit and miss with the
former being better there but in this
case they really knocked it out the park
anyway in the present we see how the
Scrolls have started to rock the boat
with the fxn people suggesting World War
III is coming Priscilla or Vara suggests
that it's poison and it's a criticism
that's often levied against opinion
based news saying he's retired Fury's
now taking up revenge and it's clear
that he only really wants to ask her
about gravic now going up this scene you
can tell Vara cares greatly about Fury
but it doesn't feel like that feeling's
reciprocated the snap has massively
changed him and during this time she
grieved for him him for five years even
when he returned though he was never
really present and you can start to see
why he then fled to saber it's a great
scene I think and they do so much with
it to show Fury never really had
anything keeping him on earth now
Priscilla is also going to be something
graphic and weaponized and I don't think
it's a coincidence that it was her who
introduced the character to Nick in
episode 2. we know from the trailers
that Nick will be returning to that
location in Brixton now we've also had
shots with Kyra and his wife back to
back showing things do tie together now
obviously the big elephant in the room
at the moment is what she gets shot at
the end however we have seen from the
trailers at the shots that haven't been
used of her yet so she's clearly not
dead my guess is that she's gonna
survive this gunshot wound though there
may be something else going on which
we'll talk a bit more about in theater
time in just a bit either way he clearly
doesn't trusts her and this is Meriden
gravic's feelings for Gaia the thing
with the Scrolls is that their entire
race is built on deception and lies and
it makes trusting each other absolutely
impossible the thing is that they do
betray each other as well and that
notion obviously ties into the title of
this entry
it's one thing I've been thinking here
is kind of scroll shape shift into
another scroll now what I mean by that
is what if Talos is pretending to be
gravic who's pretending to be Gaia
pretending to be Talos pretending to be
Talos what we do see that Scrolls can
all shift and look like gravic and that
might not even be an original version of
him now there's just this idea that it's
not all As It Seems and when you look at
the trailers there are clues that people
might be combating things in smarter
ways than we know re-watching the tears
that we see Fury come down in a ship
that then opens up and shows him looking
mean this was obviously referencing
Close Encounters of the Third Kind and
it's how it appeared in that first
episode right
if you compare those moments side by
side you'll notice that Nick's actually
wearing different clothes with the one
we haven't seen yet being more like his
classic look now there are other
possibilities here and potentially he
returned to saber to go and grab his
gear they always do this thing with the
downtrodden and out of Step Heroes where
they get back in the swing of things and
return in their old gear looking like
you when you go out on a night out out
and force your old earring back through
this ship might just be something that
eases to get around him but episode 1
showed that it seemed to just go back
and forth between Earth and the
satellite now when you're fighting an
enemy that can look like anyone you
might also employ the same tactics and
it's possible that the Nick we've seen
is actually a Skrill himself he has used
them before and saber itself has got
Skrill agents on it which we saw at the
end of Spider-Man far from home now it's
also possible that he might be an lmd
why yes it's something we've been saying
for a couple of weeks now and lmds were
used heavily in the comics known as life
model decoys these Androids perfectly
mimicked someone and the one in control
used them for very dangerous missions
before the events of secret Invasion
Nick actually went to Maria and wonder
that he suspected something was off
about the government and he said that if
I suspect something stuff about you love
I'm gonna shoot you dead too soon now
what he also did was that he stoled at
the start using lmds and said that if
you have a funny feeling in your gut
then just send them in instead Nick
could be doing this here or it could be
absolutely nothing and he may just go
back to cyber and arm up and move out
I'm Nick Fury
even when I'm out
I'm in anyway that's in it your time
stupid
now graphic lands in London with Gaia
which is where we learn Talos has called
for a poly meeting about his daughter he
of course knows she's in a lot of danger
due to her basically feeding him Intel
and telling him what's going on gravic
is aware that the police arrived far too
soon last week and though she said it
was broken he's clearly not buying it
this leads to him shooting her at the
end and I think this paranoia might be
what leads to his downfall
[Music]
now this all takes place in London's
National Portrait Gallery which is where
we see a big showdown between Talos and
gravic Talos is your leader but this
series is shown how much his forces have
now got an abandon him he goes there
alone whereas we see in the case of
gravic that he has people in every
single place they all wear his face too
and for all intents and purposes
carrying not only his lurk but
everything he stands for we get a sort
of I am Spartacus scene later on with
him standing up appearing as him ready
to show how much the scrolls are now
everything he embodies now the gallery
is running an exhibit called the faces
of Freedom which contains several
portraits of leaders renowned for their
historic conflicts this includes Winston
Churchill and it of course speaks to the
war that's currently going on however I
think the use of the word Freedom shows
what the Scrolls think of themselves and
they see themselves Fighting For Freedom
so they no longer have to remain hidden
this location has clearly been chosen
for a reason though and the eyes kind of
just follow you around the room almost
making you feel even more paranoid now
the pair initially took in front of a
giant painting and this is Statesman of
World War One by Sir James Guthrie this
was actually made in 1939 years before
the second world war started and it
chronicled the leaders of parliament all
coming together gravic sees them as just
posing for pictures as these older men
never fought in the conflicts themselves
and instead they sent young men off to
fight and die in the front line This
somewhat reflects gravic and Nick due to
the latter being an older man that sent
the Scrolls up to spy for him now I
might not have my facts right on this
but I'm sure this painting was also put
in place to give the idea that we should
be careful when entering Wars World War
One caused countless lives and it was
such a devastating Conflict for the
country however nine years later after
the painting was completed the second
world war started which was of course
also tragic too I think this mirrors how
the pair lived through the crease scroll
war and they could be walking into
something that could potentially bring
their people to Extinction Graphics high
on sugar he's gone crazy now the Scrolls
have different tides to humans which we
saw demonstrated by the length of time
Bido had gone without eating he had that
lovely scroll fruit in the car but it's
also symbolic of how they're rejecting
Humanity they cancel it integrated
themselves and were eating our food just
like how Priscilla was chopping things
up last week Talos even has he has a
full English later on and it's tough to
it's enough to bring a tear to me be all
British hot now gravic on the other hand
rejects this and he has full cups of
sugar which strangely my uncle used to
do and he tended to sniff them off
tables which was a bit weird when I
looked back at it
and Nick Fury had his big scenes again
so that actors last week and this one
feels like it's taluses I love this
moment in the gallery and it could end
up being talus's last true stand against
this villain I get the feeling that
Talos is probably gonna die in the
series and we have had hints towards is
popping up at certain points in the
trailer now this is just me guessing
because because there's not been
anything to confirm it but we do know
that the Convoy attack on President
ritzen is coming soon there's a shot
from the teaser where Talos looks badly
injured and another one where Gaia leans
over someone weeping I'm guessing this
could be for her dad no they did put it
in the trailer which is a bit obvious
looking back at it so maybe it's Beto or
something but I think making graphic
responsible for a parent's deaths will
add a lot to her character again Gaia
clearly this entire like what we see at
the end and potentially she may have
taken the super scroll serum though that
is slightly unlikely a huge thank you to
everyone for following the videos and
channel and if you want to support us
and get something back we've just
launched a secret Invasion slash Pulp
Fiction that's overall merch store
shop zeroedition.com and look at it
we've got Nick Furious Jewels here and
Talos he's doing bloody John Travolta
Vincent Vega I think it was no huge
anyway huge thank you to everyone who's
got one so far much love and thank you
for supporting this spoiler Invasion
that's what this is all about is it
you're gonna take out people
to the edge of Extinction with the war
with the human all these miscreants know
is murder natalos and gravic have a
great back and forth where they argue
their points but they've seen firsthand
what war can do when the pair both lost
their loved ones when fighting against
the cree this has had a major effect on
them though both sides see the conflict
from different angles kravik's parents
died alongside him whilst fighting in
the battles and during his Escape he
only made it up by the skin of his teeth
due to him just being a child he's been
inspired by his parents dying on the
front line and instead views their
deaths as something to be admired sorry
to hear about your parents
they died a brilliant death this is why
he has no qualms about pushing the
Scrolls to the brink of Extinction in a
war with the humans as he doesn't view
death as something one should fear now
on the flip side of this Talos got to
keep his family animate his home on
Earth with them however it's gravic's
conflict with the human that's caused
him to lose both his wife and daughter
and he knows his pain something that
will be shared by others if they go down
this path now graphic sees this is just
murdering one another and being selfish
last week even said how he liked dogs
compared to us and looked down on the
council for trying to be human all
dressed up in the man's finery drinking
the man's wine playing the man's game
using the man's fork and knife his whole
ideology seems to be that scroll Stone
kill each other which is something you
made clear at that same meeting
you'll not be harmed however he had no
qualms about it later on but he had this
murder carried out in the woods away
from the eyes of his people chose what
he's really like and he's probably more
human than he'd like to admit we all
have our bad sides can get consumed with
hate do things like not liking the video
and so on but we have our good sights
too now this to me is represented in
Talos who offers the opposite argument
to graphic Telus knows that though
humans turn on each other that when
we're threatened as a species we'll put
our differences to the side and then
work together it's this ethos that form
the Avengers and it's gonna lead to more
scroll deaths they're at their most
formidable
when they're threatened Attalla says
that if stuff continues then he's just
gonna snitch grabbing things that this
will lead to a full-on genocide of the
Scrolls but Talus will show people that
his side is different just like humans
there are good and bad guys and Telos is
willing to take first Blood against
gravic to show that he's serious now we
see that gravic uses the power of
extremists to heal the wounds showing
that he's already gone ahead with his
experiments again potentially if Gaia
has taken this then she can heal from
that wound which could explain how she's
back in the later entries now when Talus
goes outside there's a girl who raises
her hand and I was wondering if this was
the same one that had the ball in
episode one don't think it is but either
way guy gives Talus a phone with a
Neptune note on it and in a nice little
bit of continuity we can see the guy she
posed as further down the street he's on
the phone which he wouldn't have if he
was the one who just give it over and
therefore we can surmise that this was
actually Gaia hope that makes sense what
I've just said because super early and
I'm a bit run down but you know we're
fighting our own fight in this this
spoiler invasion so yeah thanks for
sticking with your boy see a chump
anyway Nick and Talos get a great scene
together after their Fallout on the
train the day before Fury now has a lead
on a scroll who's high up in the US
government but man's gonna have to say
these words first
cause I'm useless without it such a
funny exchange with them and I know that
the show is getting slated by not having
much comedy but yeah I prefer the jokes
being driven by the characters rather
than the rather than those Marvel
projects where we get the writers
clearly sitting down and being like
let's write it let's write a crap joke
anyway Neptune trivial to be the
submarine and we see that Sonya's
discovered his bug adding an eye patch
to it this is a cool little joke to time
with Fury obviously you you get it
you're a smart guy but interestingly we
have other shots from the trailer of her
examining this so potentially it may
turn up again I kind of get the feeling
that she'll put a contact lens back on
it and then have a meeting with a guy
and this will allow Fury to oversee the
entire thing however this shot could be
a deleted scene from episode 102 which
he discovered that he'd been spying on
her either way she suspects that Tony
Kern tipped off graphic and
interestingly he's appeared in the
franchise before Curran played ball back
in Thor the Dark World and it is
possible that this is where he got the
look we first saw the pair talking back
in episode one and this was the guy in
the Hologram that appeared to Fury she
she's clearly trying to flush out the
traitor in her own ranks and this is
something that's reflected in gravic
who's trying to get Gaia at this point
we learn about Commodore Robert
Fairbanks who pretty much takes up the
third Act of the episode on the way to
his house Talus talks about how he
doesn't understand why humans care for
dogs and this is kind of an opposite to
graphic last week he said that he
actually likes dogs and I tell you if
skrulls don't like dogs a lot of them
that can bloody sod off now we find out
how much the Scrolls have really helped
Fury and the man pretty much owes his
entire career to them they've kind of
been cast to the side though with Fury
not really acknowledging how much
they've helped him obviously it's
offering some social commentary and
again it ties back to the painting that
we saw at the art gallery those in the
picture are the ones who gain Fame from
the war when it was more than simply
them carrying out the battles now
sneaking into Fairbanks home their
covers quickly blown now we see that
squirrel's make up almost every unit of
his home Fairbank tries to the Earth
Fury up by posing as Talos but he messes
up and calls him Nick as we Landing
Captain Marvel nobody calls him this but
yeah I'm sure last week people did but
it might have been Nicholas but I'm
looking at you Rody but I'll have to
double check but in the end it gives
them away instantly this is why the
memory program that the Scrolls have at
the plants so important as it means that
they can't get caught out by silly
mistakes obviously though they wouldn't
know that no one calls Fury Nick and
it's clear that even with all the info
they still can get caught out in the
comics this was a big thing that gave
them away and they actually use secret
Invasion as a way to explain some out of
character moments that happened in Civil
War a theory obviously gloats about
saving his life because the whole we did
this speech but tensions rise when we
see the plan falling into place Fairbank
is loyal to gravic but Samuel L Jackson
channels his jewels interrogation
methods that he hadn't pulled fiction
super tense because the sub could launch
an attack on the UN and to make matters
worse Talos kills Fairbank this is
because he taunts him about Gaia and it
was clear with gravic that this was a
very sore point now on this Earth we
actually get up close in person with the
leading scroll agent and we know that
this character is called xerxu he
actually pulls directly from the comics
and at one point he even posed as
diabolic adelos calls guy directly and
we watch he turns against her people and
finally steps out the shadows as she
rushes through the compound we get not
only the council members but also the
real Fair bank and later one of the
scientists that was working on the super
Scrolls Gaia figures out the code with
Zachary and as we learn this was the
name of his son initially I thought when
he said Zachary that that was the
scroll's name but yeah nice little
reveal even if it's on the nose either
way Gaia has now compromised herself
Bowie watches she heads out into the
night nice little touch here is that she
doesn't turn the headlight on on her
bike and this is so that she can't be
spotted in the dark however the lack of
a God on the door does kind of give it
away and we learned that Graphics use
the plane as a way to flush out the
trailer graphic resorts to shooting her
again going back to how he'll kill
Scrolls and this symbolizes how he could
lead them to Extinction it's very
similar how they kill Maria Hill but
yeah I did feel like Marvel's ruined it
because of what we've seen in the
trailers they did the same thing with
Fury showing up at the start of the
Marvels too and I kind of wish that the
marketing would just hold things back
now we see his Vara heads out and
withdraws a gun from a safety deposit
box then we learned she's been in
contact with gravic all along again I
think she'll be used as a deal by him
and she's probably getting called in as
a way to draw Fury out whether it works
or not we don't know because he seems
like he doesn't really care and maybe
yeah maybe you should have shape-shifted
into Naomi Campbell in the 90s
God damn that wraps up the episode and
we're kinda heading into potential leaky
and spoiler stuff now so if you don't
want to know anything then turn off now
the first of these is more of a theory
whereas the seconds are full on leak so
enter the next part of the video at your
own Peril and the first part of this
builds off the back of an image that
leaked around the time of black panther
wakanda forever originally it was said
that the studio shot scenes for the film
that in the end would reveal Dr Doom was
in the MCU these were scrapped but some
apparent concept art came out and it
ended up showing a very specific scene
looking at it now a lot of people have
said the person Doom's facing could in
fact be gravic and that this scene might
have set up the events happening in the
show well that's the case in art there's
been a lot of talk about Doctor Doom
recently because Ben Mendelson gave a
hilarious interview talking about the
character Victor Von Doom is the
greatest single character in the entire
MCU
he's the first character to ever have a
substantive backstory that we could
understand and that gives context both
in the old traditional Cold War minor
State kind of idea and also as someone
who really got disfigured got his family
taken from him and then takes all that
takes his skill has the wounds and has
to wear the mask and continues on to do
what he did the Fantastic Force suck
right they suck full stop they they're
sort of like Marvel's first attempt to
make a group and they suck right that's
why the X-Men Rule and Fantastic Four
suck however the Fantastic Four birth
the Scrolls and they both Dr Doom so
while they stuck they also gave rise to
the greatest two villain groups and
single villain ever now you can keep
anyone else give me Dr Doom against
anyone because Victor suffers and you
will now suffer you know that's
that's that's why it's a no-brainer give
me
give me the success from that lame-ass
group of like flame on flame on in case
you don't know Dr Doom civilian in
secret Wars and there's been theories
that they might replace Kang with him
because of what's happening with
Jonathan Majors I don't know if that
will happen but with Fantastic Four
coming soon the inclusion of super
Scrolls and so on they may tease towards
them coming in the show the cast for
that will probably be announced very
soon but hey like I said we are gonna
see anyway that's a video Yeah it ended
it on a crap note there but obviously
let me know your thoughts on the episode
below I know this show is also short of
the million viewer mark from episode one
so I'd also love to hear your thoughts
on the MCU and Disney Plus in general I
am working on a video talking about it
so I'd love to hear your opinions and
yeah let me know if you think the mcu's
kind of dwindling into nothing now if
you want to support the channel for as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below and as a
tank you'll get early access to videos
every week if you want something else to
watch we've got a video on screen right
now and hopefully you see you over there
right after this if not enjoy the rest
of your week hope to see you back for
the next one you take care yourself and
have a good weekend by the way I've been
poor you've been the best and I'll see
you next time take care peace